it is great to be joined today by Peter
simi who is a professor of sociology at
Chapman University also co-author with
Robert Petrella of the book American
swastika inside the white power
movements hidden spaces of hate so much
to talk about particularly now but maybe
we'll start sort of with how you first
started researching in in this area from
a pretty early age I read you were sort
of aware of and kind of cataloguing
racist incidents that you would observe
how did you first get into this well
yeah
so starting pretty young around maybe
the age about nine I did do that you
know I wasn't doing research per se cuz
I didn't know what that was I was
noticing things in my environment that
you know appeared to be racist and and
that was something an interest that was
sparked in part by growing up with they
come an older brother / father figure
who's african-american and kind of seen
racist things kind of looking at it from
his perspective and then also my mother
kind of at a young age taught me about
hate groups and kind of the history of
hate groups and we watched a PBS
documentary about the Ku Klux Klan and a
pretty young age that made a big impact
on me and so you know starting starting
early on I was just trying to really
understand kind of why there are these
kind of beliefs and feelings about
different groups based on racial
differences or religious differences or
sexual orientation but really in grad
school about 1996 I started formally
studying hate groups and then in the
winter of 97 I actually started spending
time with active members of hate groups
so let's let's go to that I mean how
does that start because you know our
audience will remember when I
interviewed Darryl Davis who spends time
with KKK members neo-nazis white
supremacist without sort of trying he
has his relationships have led to many
of them abandoning their beliefs talk a
little bit about you not as a black man
like
Harold Davis how you started spending
time with these groups yeah I mean
Darryl's work is amazing
but his approach is a little bit
different because I'm coming out more as
a kind of a researcher trying to
understand these individuals and the
groups that they belong to on their
terms so I'm I'm trying to build
relationships in a way to where they
feel comfortable kind of opening up to
me about how they got involved and what
their you know thoughts are and views
are about the world so I'm using a very
kind of approach where I'm trying to
build rapport where I'm trying to make
them feel like in some ways I might be
sympathetic to them and so there's you
know some ethical issues obviously
involved with that but it I felt it was
necessary for folks to feel comfortable
to feel like they weren't being judged
by me to kind of you know you're not in
agreement with things you don't agree
with you you know you you listen a lot
and and and really you know don't offer
necessarily any critical feedback about
things in order for them to kind of open
up to you and so that that process for
me you know I started by writing a
letter to a group they had a Pio box
this is 1997 so it's the early days of
the internet and this group responded
back I told them basically I wanted to
meet real people involved with these
groups and compare it to media
demonization and I used those words on
purpose because I knew that already that
they felt you know they basically
victimized they feel like the media and
others you know view them and in a
particular way that kind of stigmatizes
them and and marginalizes them and so
they have this real strong sense of
victimization and so I wanted to try and
appeal to that basically in hopes that
that might resonate with them and it
seemed to and they said they'd be
willing to meet with me and so from
there we met in person and then they
after the initial meeting they said I
could come back and stay with them in
their homes and crash on their you know
couch in the front room type of thing
sand when you're with some of these
individuals other than the white
supremacist neo-nazi KKK whatever
beliefs is it otherwise sort of like
just hanging out with your friends or
are there some other sort of key
differences that
pervade their entire day-to-day you know
it's a little bit of both I mean there
are some eerie you're kind of eerie
similarities where you feel like wow
this is a lot like hanging out with
people I've went to school with and and
there's some similarities there on the
other hand you know there's for for the
folks that are deeply involved and
strongly committed to these views and
the larger movement I mean it really is
a lifestyle to where it permeates their
everyday living in the sense of where
they decorate their homes in some cases
with say portraits of Hitler or you know
have Nazi banners that kind of thing
around the home they watch TV in a
particular way so they filter the news
through there kind of white supremacist
lens so even watching a TV show can
become a big you know there where
they're kind of complaining about
multiculturalism they're complaining
about liberalism that kind of thing yeah
you know going to the grocery store can
become an ordeal because they happen to
you know get cut off in the driver
coincidentally happens to be someone of
a different racial or ethnic group and
this turns into a big you know commotion
so in a way that there's certain
similarities in a way that you know
because their lifestyle is such that
where they're so committed to these
beliefs
it really does distinguish them in some
pretty dramatic ways when I read the
book Donnie Brasco which of course is
the retelling by former undercover FBI
agent Joe Pistone of his time undercover
with the New York different families of
the New York Mafia he talks about being
around homophobic comments and
anti-semitic comments and that type of
thing and sort of adopting an attitude
of kind of like a nonchalance and and
kind of like indifference he doesn't
participate but again he's playing a
character as an undercover FBI agent do
you feel as though when you are with
these individuals in a sense you're
playing a character because you are
being upfront about the fact that you're
doing research at the same time you're
not reacting to each comment in the way
you would maybe as an academic what's
your sense of your role in that in that
way
I think there are some interesting
similarities there I mean you do I think
you know we all play roles in different
situations that we developed to kind of
navigate that situation or adapt to the
environment and in this particular
environment I felt like I had to do that
to be able to get along and so yeah I
did laugh at jokes that I thought were
disgusting you know I did not an
approval about ideas that the white race
is on the verge of extinction you know I
don't believe that obviously but these
are things that I had to kind of feign
agreement about I didn't run around I
wasn't doing Nazi salutes or dressing
like you know in their uniforms or
things like that but there were
occasions even where depending on the
gathering you know in some circumstances
people actually just assumed that I was
part of their group I was part of a
different group that was associated with
with the event and so in some cases
people just assumed that I was one of
them and if they would you know if they
if they made that assumption clear to me
then I would correct them but if they
didn't then I would just let them assume
whatever they assumed so you know and in
some of the gatherings where there's a
lot you know fairly large number of
people obviously it's not possible for
everyone to know that you're you're
there doing research so some folks just
assume that you're an attendee like they
are so it did require developing a kind
of certain persona that was not that was
very different than obviously Who I am
really yeah you know in in an authentic
sense so what did your research turn up
about the sort of entryway into these
beliefs I've interviewed Scott Shepherd
former KKK Frankie mink who's a former
former neo-nazi and for the most part
they describe a situation of a childhood
that was missing something and sort of
situations of opportunity where someone
came to them with beliefs that were part
of a community they wanted community and
that that's how they sort of got sucked
in are those stories the exception or do
you find that they are predominant in
those circles no and I should mention
that since 2012 in addition to doing the
field work with active members we've
been interviewing formers like like
Scott and Frankie
we've now interviewed 104 former white
supremacists so we're able to least get
a sense of kind of different kinds of
patterns in terms of entry as well as
how folks end up leaving and you know I
think both of the factors that you point
to seem pretty consistent across the
board I mean again you know these you
know people for lots of different
reasons and in lots of different ways so
there's certain you know degree of
diversity in terms of how people get
involved in these groups as well as how
they leave but those are patterns that
we do see you know pretty commonly
emerge across the board and I should
also point out we also see folks talking
a lot about their childhood upbringing
in terms of family members who are not
members of these groups for the most
part I mean we do have a certain portion
of folks that we've interviewed who grew
up literally in families where you know
that from day one they were
indoctrinated from day one they were
socialized to be involved in these kind
of groups but that's fairly rare
fortunately but what folks do report
growing up around is kind of this more
everyday racism where they're hearing
you know the n-word they're hearing
other racial epithets and and and other
words negative words to describe
different racial ethnic religious groups
they're hearing ideas that kind of
communicate certain kind of homophobia
anti-semitism racism at home in a way
that's kind of somewhat innocuous you
might say and I think it desensitizes
them to the extent to where when they do
come in contact with these more extreme
groups that have more extreme beliefs
about these issues it's it's not as far
of a bridge to cross for them
because they've had this background and
of course unfortunately in our society a
lot of people grow up around that so
it's certainly not you know the only
factor but but I think it is an
important factor that we should keep in
mind in terms of that you know this very
pervasive everyday racism that continues
to persist and in our society when we
will talk in part two of the interview
about the current political climate but
before we get to that specifically sure
when it comes to people that get out of
these movements
when I speak to folks like Daryl Davis
for example the people he knows who get
out tend to be more on the side of they
reconsider their beliefs and they
realized that they were wrong or their
views are deplorable or discriminatory
whatever my sense is that that is
probably more of an exception and that
for a lot of people that get out it
relates more to it's causing a specific
problem with their significant other
it's causing an employment problem or
that type of thing where do you think
that the balance falls on that yeah Deb
a ston you know the day that we've
collected is definitely the ladder for
you know the majority of folks it's you
know people get involved for certain
reasons they think they're going to have
certain needs met you know in other
words when we have our needs met we tend
to have a higher level of satisfaction
with whatever it is we're involved in
and as people's needs are not met they
become dissatisfied with things that
they're involved in and in that sense
this is a lot like that that you know
people find a lot of hypocrisy in these
movements they find a lot of
backstabbing they find a lot of
interpersonal disputes and drama and
they find in many cases people are
saying one thing and doing another and
and so as these kind of kind of this
disenchantment starts to build people
start to you know say well what why am I
actually doing this is it really giving
me what I thought it would give me and
then that's where the distance from the
group starts to get generated it seems
and then later on in some cases folks do
start to really kind of evaluate their
beliefs and and by having distance from
the group that gives them a chance to
really rethink things now I should point
out in some cases people leave these
groups but they don't change their
beliefs you know I continue to have the
same beliefs they're just not
necessarily involved in a formal group
or something
let's pause our conversation there we've
been speaking with Peter simi who's
professor of sociology at Chapman
University co-author of the book with
Robert fat rel American swastika inside
the white power movements hidden spaces
of hate and we will pick up our
conversation with him right there